family and friends of dmx are holding a
prayer vigil tonight at the hospital
where the acclaimed rapper and actor is
fighting for his life
we spoke with a member of his inner
circle to get the latest developments
[Music]
my music is not just for the moment it's
forever
i'm at the crossroads look but i'm not
really sure which way to go
he is presently on life support he has
his family with him he has
close friends with him a source close to
dmx tells et that his loved ones are
quote standing by his bedside holding
his hand and praying
outside the hospital in new york
hundreds of rough rider bikers gathered
to show their support
and from ll cool j to eminem and snoop
dogg stars sent their love and prayers
so what happened we're told the 50 year
old whose real name is earl simmons was
rushed to the hospital after suffering a
heart attack on friday
quote they tried to revive him twice in
the house and they revived him again
in the hospital we've also learned that
dmx suffered from covet 19
and recently had a relapse with
substance abuse do you have a drug
problem now
i will always have a drug problem just
because you stopped getting high doesn't
mean that you don't have the problem
because it's a constant fight every day
this was the last time dmx was seen out
in public heading to an atlanta club in
february
wanna fight me fight these tears he was
making a movie
he had just completed an album to the
best of my knowledge
the rapper has released eight studio
albums each album has to do many things
and has appeared in 16 movies he talked
to us ahead of the release of cradle to
the grave after gq called him
the next tom cruise to be compared to
someone of his caliber
is overwhelming you know
but if they believe it that's what's up
he was always working that's all he
lived to do was work i would say
really a great poet of our time
[Music]